this is a significant day because it is
their first official engagement since uh
Royal morning came to an end and we are
once again back in Scotland of course it
was here in Scotland that the queen died
so already it feels like Scotland's seen
an awful lot of the royal family since
her passing but I think today for the
King again it is that chance to to
reinforce his fondness for Scotland and
try and reinforce that relationship
because of course Scotland's fondness
for the monarchy mainly came down to the
fact that they had such huge respect for
the queen so it is now time for the new
king to make his own Mark in lots of
ways the fact that he's in dunfermline
is because the town has been conferred
with City status it's one of eight towns
across the country that was given that
honor because of the Queen's Platinum
Jubilee and so he's here today to mark
that moment if you know Dan Thurman well
he's quite proud of its Royal history
anyway King Charles the first was the
last monarch been born here back in 1600
and then three years after that his
father King James VI then took on the
crown of England so it was a combination
of the crowns at that moment so it is a
place that already has a proud raw
history and today in a way is starting
another chapter for that of course I
think what's going to be really
interesting over the coming weeks is
that we are going to see a lot more of
this new monarch than we did the queen
of course she was 96 years old she was
becoming increasingly frail
King Charles is yes 73 years old but you
know he does have a really strong work
ethic he wants to get out and about and
meet as many people as possible but I
think of course with that yes hopefully
comes the opportunity for people to get
to know him but also I think means
probably a greater level of scrutiny in
terms of what he says and what he does